they've long since submitted themselves
as beloved pop culture icons but what do
we really know about Jay and his
longtime companion Silent Bob we've
compiled an exhaustive timeline of the
lives loves trials and good fortunes of
this foul-mouthed dynamic duo if you're
wondering where the story of Jay and
Silent Bob begins it might be best to
start with Genesis the book of the Bible
not the BAM yes the biblical story of
creation is canon within kevin smith's
universe and it's more relevant than you
might think
as outlined in dogma the stories of the
Bible hold literal sway in the view
askew naver's with biblical figures
including God herself
showing up to influence the events of
the world and also to kill people in the
beginning God created all that is
developed an unknowable plan for
existence and looks suspiciously like
Alanis Morissette while a lot of the
events depicted in the holy texts are
presented as subjective and even
misleading turns out the story was in
broad strokes pretty accurate Bible hey
hey the Holy Bible son why is this
important well aside from answering
man's most fundamental questions about
nature being and the nature of existence
it sets the stage nicely for two stoners
to meet at a convenience store in New
Jersey in the 1970s the place the
unincorporated community of Leonardo New
Jersey just outside the quick stop the
time the 1970s what is about to occur is
nothing short of destiny
what the hell excuse me who's watching
these babies I did that one's watching
the little one just like that Jay and
Silent Bob were United
hetero life mates from the cradle to the
grave also did you know Kevin Smith's
daughter is playing baby Silent Bob it's
a screen debut it's adorable
that's right savages the second movie
and the Esk universe takes place before
the first here's how you can tell most
of Mallrats revolves around a dating
game show run by Michael Rooker's
character Machiavelli and Jared spinning
after tragedy strikes the original
contestant spendings daughter brandi is
forced to replace her on the game show
at the last minute my dad's asked me to
help him with his new show what like
what like his assistant or as a
contestant you mean that dating game
ripoff thing that is what you're talking
about here right
the original contestant is named Julie
Dwyer wanting to look skinny for the
cameras she goes on an ill-advised
exercise binge at the YMCA pool
unexpectedly dying of a brain embolism
in the process this disaster triggers
the plot of mall rats with the boyfriend
of spendings daughter Quint and his
friend Brody ending up in a cartoonish
farce with Jay and Silent Bob at the
local mall where the gameshow is being
shot in the end Quint wins over his
girlfriend Ben Affleck goes to jail and
were promised that Jay and Silent Bob
will get an orangutan someday and they
will just not yet this brings us to
clerks Kevin Smith's first movie in this
film quick stop employee Dante and his
pal Randall attend Julie Dwyers wake
placing the movie directly after the
events of mall rats it's like the
Indiana Jones movies but with more pop
clerks introduced the world to Jay and
Silent Bob scumbag supporting characters
who serve as counter points to the main
characters dour minimum-wage existence
they also serve this bounce of wisdom
and a STONER Greek chorus Jay and Silent
Bob spend majority of clerks doing what
they do best they hang out in front of
the quick stop slinging drugs while Jay
makes noise and Bob doesn't at first
glance the romantic comedy chasing Amy
doesn't feel like a Jay and Silent Bob
story at all with no smoochies nor boo
cheese to be found this is a movie about
Smith mainstays Ben Affleck and Jason
Lee played creative partners on a comic
book series titled Bluntman and chronic
which details the lives and adventures
of two vigilante stoners one life loud
and obnoxious the other portly and less
verbal they are of course based on Jay
and Silent Bob who Ben Affleck's
character Holden goes to meet at a diner
to pay them their royalties for their
likeness rights bear Silent Bob delivers
his biggest Beach to date giving the
movie its title the chasing amy he also
reveals an unprecedented number of
details about his own personal life
including the lifelong desire to be a
dancer but there's more backstory to
this scene than the movies even fill you
in on before they go to meet Holden Jay
and Silent Bob crashed in the living
room of Mallrats character Trish Jones
sister - chasing Amy's Alyssa Jones in a
story that connects the stoners aren't
for Mallrats to the movies that follow a
four-issue comic book miniseries chasing
Dogma bridges the gap between chasing
Amy and Dogma finally answering the
question hey what do you think Jay and
Bob were doing around 1998 Sroka we go
we're doing coke drink and fist drinking
beers beers business smokes blunts we
smoke the bunch here's the basic
synopsis after Jay gets the two of them
thrown out of Trish's house the duo
heads to the malls department store to
watch John Hughes movies on VHS they get
in a fight then get kicked out of the
rst video parking lot they then head to
Shermer Illinois to try to sell weed to
the brat pack characters then get
verbally assaulted by mr. Rogers
eventually landing work on the set of an
adult film directed by Neil Patrick
Harris called Doogie Knights and that's
all in the first two issues in a weird
twist issue three explores their
adoption of an escaped orangutan and
subsequent scrapes with a federal
wildlife marshal which will sound
familiar to some yes that particular
storyline from Jay and Silent Bob strike
back apparently happened twice at the
end of the run Jay and Silent Bob
discovered that there is no Shermer
Illinois and decide to bury their
disappointment by heading to a family
planning clinic to meet women they're
nothing if not consistent theologically
speak
everything sort of comes to a head for
New Jersey's favorite unlicensed herbal
peddlers in 1999 when while cruising at
the clinic they meet Bethany Sloane the
last descendant of a genetic line shared
by Jesus Christ this is the movie in
which Jay and Bob are revealed to be
prophets sent by God which still isn't
ironic though it is amusing Jay and Bob
escort Bethany on an interstate journey
of self-discovery and heavy religious
introspection along the way they
befriend Rufus the secret 13th apostle
and serendipity amused responsible for
some of history's most financially
successful box-office performances
Silent Bob proves to be a remarkably
effective demon slayer defeating two
actual demons over the course of the
adventure Jay has less success and his
attempts to kill a fallen angel with an
Uzi mostly makes things worse still
through offhand remarks he takes a
potential end-of-the-world scenario off
the burner and helps to save God from a
comatose state and Kurd during one of
the all my T's trips down to earth to
play skee-ball Bethany immaculately
conceived a holy child and according to
Kevin Smith that's all we'll be hearing
on the matter after four movies and
various side projects in the supporting
cast 2001's Jay and Silent Bob strike
back but the fare center stage the movie
sees the duo learning two important
things one Hollywood is adapting blood
man and cronic into a big-budget
blockbuster they deserve a cut of the
royalties to the internet exists and
people are mean there we got to put a
stop to these painful sons before they
ruin our good names the to head off to
Hollywood to try to shut down the movie
or at least get paid their share for
their likenesses along the way they
befriend a quartet of female jewel
thieves masquerading as animal rights
activists and are conned into stealing
an orangutan from an animal testing
facility as part of an elaborate
cover-up Bob and the 8 become dear
friends jay falls in love with one of
the criminals and will ferrell appears
as a Will Ferrell character the jewel
thieves are arrested after justice the
member
the group who garnered Jays affections
turns them in to save Jay and Bob from
going down for a crime they didn't
commit
she asked Jay to wait for her while
she's incarcerated Jay and Bob
confronted Banky Edwards the co-creator
of Bluntman and chronic played by Jason
Lee and walk away with the cherry cut of
the proceeds from the forthcoming
feature film leaving them financially
solvent for the foreseeable future
shockingly in the years between Jay and
Silent Bob strike back and clerks to the
beloved quick stop burned at the ground
our boys aren't to blame though they
were in rehab at the time as chronicled
by Jay during his first day back at work
they bought a car but were pulled over
for suspicion of mischief also known as
driving Rollins deployed airbag the
police found marijuana and their vehicle
and the dynamic duo were sentenced to
six months of rehab back on the outside
they continued dealing drugs but stopped
using they also seemingly picked their
business venue based solely on where
Dante and Randall were working at the
time setting up shop in front of a
movies fast-food restaurant they keep
themselves in the background to the most
part silent bob achieves his dance
dreams and a sequence of heightened
reality and the two are arrested again
during a madcap comedy of errors
surrounding a donkey show put on inside
the restaurant after everyone gets taken
to jail the two offered to finance Dante
and Randall's reclamation of the rebuilt
quick stop in exchange for a permanent
residency in front of the store as the
credits roll a line of text reads Jay
and Silent Bob might return someday
until then they're taking it easy fans
speculated as to whether or not they'd
ever see their heroes again 13 years
passed and then after a decade-long
career detour with studio comedies Zack
and Miri Make a Porno and cop out as
well as a dark horror phase centered on
the great white north of canada Kevin
Smith decided he was ready to go back
into the viewest universe the return is
officially kicking off in October 2019
remember the plot of Jay and Silent Bob
strike back kevin smith has described
the sequel as being basically the same
movie even comparing it to director Gus
Van Sant's shot-for-shot psycho remake
where we take it from Gus Gus I'm busy
your true are discuss the movie will
follow Jay and Silent Bob as they try to
stop a big-budget Hollywood remake of
the movie they tried to put a stop to in
strike back a ton of Smith regulars make
appearances including Ben Affleck Jason
Lee and Shannon Elizabeth reprising her
role as Justice who introduces Jade to
their love child Millie played by Kevin
Smith's kid Harley Quinn Smith she's
less adorable this time around though
this time she means business either you
take us to Hollywood or a step you both
to death on my own front lawn well like
father like kid check out one of her
newest videos right here Plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]